Brazil is at a turning point the country
just held the most important
presidential election in its history
a field of 13 candidates was narrowed
down to 2 for the final vote Fernando
Haddad represented the leftist Workers
Party which has been in power for much
of the past two decades he garnered just
under 45 percent of the vote far right
candidate dryer bosun ro who won 55
percent of the vote has been elected
Brazil's next president marking a
dramatic shift in the country's politics
that's because Boston ro is a longtime
congressman who is known for his ultra
conservative and deeply offensive
rhetoric his rhetoric has sparked
widespread protests and outrage it
became so bad that at a campaign rally
the candidate was stabbed by a man
claiming he was on a mission from God
but despite the backlash bolson ro drew
huge crowds to his rallies and
skyrocketed to the top of the polls so
how did this relatively unknown
congressman garner so much support and
what does this mean for Brazil's
democracy
Brazil hasn't been a democracy for long
the country was ruled by a military
regime from 1964 to 1985 it was an era
marked by violence torture exile and
censorship it was during this military
regime that Jo Boston ro began his
career as an army captain when the
regime fell in 1985 and Brazil became a
democracy Boston ro entered politics as
a staunch far-right conservative
eventually becoming a congressman for
Rio de Janeiro
he served seven terms in Congress but
remained controversial because of his
extremist remarks and he continued to
show an affinity for the military
dictatorship just look at these photos
in his congressional office the
portraits on the wall are presidents
from Brazil's military regime as a
presidential candidate bolson ro didn't
change he openly called for bringing
back some of the military regimes
tactics Mohammad SS car la gente el
problema Scimitar dice kids age
kun da so treat the children don't
anything is he cool their core processor
in fact Boston ro has picked a retired
Army General as his running mate who has
openly suggested that a military coup
could be a possibility who calls
Wiesenthal advice
see I leave I said respected Petrus was
a jinkies
this time though that pro-military
message struck a chord
for many Brazilians particularly the
young voters in Boston aerospace the
military regime's brutality has faded
into history instead Boston Aras praise
of the Armed Forces has resonated with
his supporters at a time when crime has
been soaring in the country in 2016
Brazil's homicide rate was nearly six
times that of the u.s. in a country that
shares borders with some of the biggest
cocaine producing countries in the world
much of Brazil's violence stems from
drug gang rivalries mismanagement of
Public Security funds by government
officials has left police in the country
underpaid and under prepared to deal
with the mounting violence Boston aras
pro-military stance has made him a
champion of law and order for many even
though his rhetoric calls back to a
brutal dictatorship Boston ro is seen as
a solution for a country in crisis say
na hora de science observer Volta origin
GDP suit economy Gennaro laughs American
singer integrity in Fairfield at some
time but Brazil's crisis isn't just
about homicides the country is still
reeling from the biggest corruption
scandal in its history in Boston ro has
capitalized on that too
for weeks Brazil has been consumed by
allegations of corruption and bribery at
the highest level involving politicians
and business leaders a massive
corruption investigation known as
Operation car wash uncovered a
money-laundering scheme that funneled
billions into the pockets of politicians
including members of major political
parties balsan ro seize the opportunity
to position himself as a political
outsider and promised to end corruption
here he is leading protests against
Dilma Rousseff Brazil's president during
the scandal he lashed out at the Workers
Party that Rousseff belonged to and
whose members had been prosecuted for
corruption no Samos Chios a fact on
Kamino Aza in kannada lopez tino zapatti
attorney quarters an AUSA 8th president
for equal value this is chief would you
movimiento 'no paulson ro was actually
one of the pivotal votes for Rousseff's
impeachment in 2016 when he openly
dedicated his vote to an army colonel
accused of widespread torture and
murders during brazil's dictatorship
the corruption scandal also helped
Boston ro by removing his strongest
opponent convicted for corruption the
man better known as Lula was forced to
bow out of October's presidential race
in September this year ex-president Lula
da Silva who was in jail for corruption
was banned from running in the
presidential race even from jail Lula
was polling far above any other
presidential candidate but when Lula was
officially barred from the race balsan
ro soared in the polls his final
opponent in the presidential race
Fernando Haddad belongs to the same
party as Lula but he didn't draw the
same level of support in part because of
the increase in crime and rampant
corruption the public's faith in the
government has eroded over the years
their trust in Congress the presidency
the Supreme Court are at an all-time low
meanwhile the public's view of the Armed
Forces is relatively favorable with
nearly eight out of ten Brazilians
supporting the institution for
Brazilians fed up with the political
ruling class Dreyer Boston ro is
offering an alternative meizu for Jubal
Sanada yes would you Jumma das question
again at went on as a fifth year history
as it was he gonna devote by his own
couch but for many others Boston arrows
offensive comments and anti-democratic
solutions are reminder of Brazil's
authoritarian past Sen democrática
democracia Tommy asada
I think that we start with really
delicious he fascist tasty no foreign
bone but it works for the democracy you
buy a thing where the Cobras use Italian
polish Polish polish his office issues
relating to be a become abrasive
arrogant a mattress commercial advantage
ordinary technical support polyneices
christiana to the jeremy titan ok pessoa
parts a photographer governor Hassan are
logically sanely latest elevator boys
our Judas pursuers in finding vintage
passage contains the origin in cobrado
my circulated oh no voice I espresso is
the LSD actually they they disagreed you
nail glue homosexual Sarah made my pesto
Aquino vo- jamala foramen ovale mumble
Adam is my man area was killing SATA it
was a day on Dukas which oversaw the
ranches seasons
[Music]